and finally new rule now that the
Republican convention is finally over
those of you thoroughly disgusted by
what you witnessed have to look on the
bright side win or lose Donald Trump
will probably be the last 50s guy to run
for president and frankly that is
something to be thankful for because
because fifties guys you know guys like
Trump who actually say I'm a 50s guy we
know what they mean I think that putting
a wife to work is a very dangerous thing
when I come home and dinners not ready I
go through the roof
yeah the 50s guy he likes steak he keeps
a bottle of scotch in his desk and he
thinks an educated woman should be
locked up I don't he does you know bill
critten really nailed it when he said if
you thought something good came out of
the 60s you're probably a Democrat and
if you thought the 60s were bad you're
probably a Republican and it's insights
like that that are gonna make him a
great first lady but that tension
between 50s and 60s people is what still
drives our politics today it's true you
wait to think the 50s were great or the
60s were great or you weren't even born
yet and you think screw all you old
farts I'm voting for someone young like
Bernie Sanders
now two sixties people like me the 50s
are kind of like America's highschool
yearbook picture
with each passing year they just get
more and more embarrassing but not to
Donald Trump he was born exactly nine
months after the end of World War two he
could have been conceived on this day
when America was on top of the world and
the young Trump family was by all
accounts very happy
when Trump was a kid Eisenhower was
always president dinner made by mom has
always on the table and the closest
thing to an ethnic guy was Fonzie people
are a product of the time they grow up
in its white Trump still wears a
pompadour albeit one that's lost the
will to live
if you're a 50s guy even when you try to
join the modern world it's useless
look at my african-american over here
look at him not that they really want to
because for Trump and his fans what was
so great about the 50s was that white
men didn't have to really try he
complains about rigged systems but the
50s was the ultimate rigged system for
example basketball teams look like this
Trump was 10 when Elvis burst on the
scene and while other people had made
music like that before
only Elvis had the insight to do it
while being white in the 50s everybody
knew their place then stayed in their
Lane
lesbians were called roommates and gay
men were called priests
on a resume a man could lift sexual
harassment under special skills a tank
of gas cost a nickel
and on a starry night you could drive up
to makeout point in your big gas
guzzling American car and get a [ __ ]
from a girl and nobody ever asked you to
check your priveledge you didn't have to
check it was there alright so when
Republicans talk about restoring America
making it great again taking their
country back this is where they want to
take it back to 1959 when life was still
in black and white before the 60s came
along and ruined everything with color
Trump never fully adapted to color
that's why he's orange
like the first color TVs his 10th knob
is a little off and he and all the 50s
guys like him hold a deep resentment for
those troublemakers and outside
agitators who came along in the 60s and
messed everything up by pointing out
that the 50s weren't that great if you
were black or gay or a woman
which is why Little Richard was always
screaming
you